welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Doug Rogers associate professor of
anthropology at Yale University his
research and teaching interests include
political and economic anthropology
natural resource extraction and energy
the Anthropology of religion and
socialist societies and their post
socialist trajectories he is done
archival and ethnographic research in
Russia since 1994 and is currently
working on an ethnography based project
titled oil culture producing the new
Russia today we'll talk with Professor
Rogers about his groundbreaking book
welcome professor Rogers sure let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it sure so the book is called
oil culture producing the new Russia and
it's in part about Russian oil and in
part about Russian culture and there's
sort of two main premises to the book
the first one is that I don't think
we've really understood very well the
place of oil in Soviet and post-soviet
history there's a lot of studies that
deal with sort of oil at the top of the
economy and you know Putin or Yeltsin
and the oligarchs and companies and
corporate histories but how the big
Russian oil boom has worked on the
ground how the Soviet oil industry
worked in practice we know a lot less
about this and so one premise of the
book is simply to sort of understand
what's going on which sort of feeds into
the second purpose which is I think
what's going on is a lot different than
what we see in other parts of the world
where oil is produced say in Nigeria or
Venezuela or Saudi Arabia or even in the
United States where there's been a lot
of study of this industry and and the
effects of an oil boom on a local
community or on a on different kinds of
social structures or cultural practices
we don't we don't know a lot about
Russia and Russia I think is going to
turn out to be quite different because
of this history and so I'm interested in
in sort of excavating I suppose this
history and then putting it in some kind
of dialogue with what we know about the
rest of the world and then exploring
some of those similarities okay
differences okay so what led you to
write the book well you know a lot of
things in research already turned out by
surprise especially in anthropology
things sort of catch you by surprise or
your your things are unexpected so I've
been going to Russia and doing fieldwork
in this particular region that I that I
studied the Perim region which is sort
of near the near the Urals so not Moscow
not European Russia and not Siberia
either somewhere in the middle I've been
going there for 20 years and I lived
there in 2000-2001 for a whole year in a
village and I was researching
agriculture and religion and how things
had changed since the end of the Soviet
Union I wrapped up that project that was
my first book and I was looking for
something new to write about and new to
think about and this was the early
mid-2000s when oil was coming a big
thing this is an oil-producing region
friends I had were going to work in the
oil industry all of a sudden people I
knew were becoming fantastically rich if
they lived in or had some association
with an oil-producing region so it
seemed like an interesting thing to dig
into right and there is very little for
you to draw upon right so that's that
was kind of you know a bit of a surprise
I would imagine well that's right I mean
there's a lot of fantastic Russian
scholarship Russian language scholarship
you know local history and people there
writing about these things but there
really hasn't been a lot of stuff
written by academics in Western Europe
or the United States that takes into
account these ground-level things people
ready to pretend to write about the big
name things that you read about in
newspapers big company deals or Putin
struggles but the oligarchs but how oil
money flows in a particular town or how
the exchange of oil gets organized or
what company is sponsoring what museum
or these things that I'm interested in
people there we're talking about there
wasn't much to go on
you see and why do you think that is
well there is a couple things I think
you know I'm from discipline
anthropology that's very
fieldwork you go and live places and
hang out and try to understand things
from the inside and it's a fairly young
discipline with respect to Russia and
the former Soviet Union in the Cold War
this was not possible you couldn't go
sure yeah anthropologists were elsewhere
in the world so it's only really since
the 1990s that Eve that any anthropology
was possible in the former Soviet Union
so there's a sort of a generation ahead
of me but I but I'm the second
generation of people who've been able to
do fieldwork so there hasn't been much
time to do these things so that's one
thing and and you know anthropologists
have only really recently become
interested in oil and energy at all so
that is not that's interesting yeah I
mean anthropologists you know the the
you know there's been some studies but
but this has not been a major focus of
attention at least in recent years some
in this in the 70s oil crisis and and
then in the World War 2 era there were
sort of little boom watts of
anthropologists interested in energy but
it's in a big way has happened in the
past few years so I think the
combination of those two things now I am
curious why did you pick that particular
area of Russia out of every other place
in the world you could have studied well
that is also a tale of coincidence that
begins really when I was an
undergraduate at Middlebury College and
I was spending my junior year abroad and
wanting to learn about religion and
things like this then I met some people
in Moscow who said well we study
religion why don't you come with us this
summer we're going out to the perm
region to study you know religious
communities and I said all right why not
you know I was a junior in college I had
the summer free so I spent the summer
out in in the rural areas with the perm
region with this crowd
and that was 1994 and I have not stopped
going back since then so it's
coincidence followed by inertia so how
did you do the research for the book
tell us about the methodology so
anthropology is a largely not entirely
but largely a field work based
discipline you go and you talk to people
so it's very much based on interviews
some of them very formal
where I have sort of a set of questions
that I definitely want to ask somebody
but I also pay a lot of attention to
informal conversations or chats that I
have with people who I meet who are
either in the oil industry or in
government or given my interest in
Russian culture and cultural fields in
say they work in museums and so it's
very much based on interviews there's
also a lot of sort of newspaper and
media research for the older part the
Soviet part there's some archival
research but it's it's assembled from
these different pieces of sort of
empirical on the ground some of which
are structured buts a lot of which are
just fortuitous that they just they just
happen and and that has allowed me to
build up these larger right right so how
let's talk about some of your findings
and and actually in doing the research
did anything you come across say wow I
wasn't anticipating about or you know
very surprised and kind of thing oh all
the time I mean I mean you know that I I
guess I've sort of gotten used to it
because you know the unexpected things
are fairly common in fieldwork and
graphic research because life is a
fairly unexpected thing and what you
want to do is capture that and not edit
it out in as your you know consider data
or something but you know I was very
surprised by and interested in the way
in which the identity of the perm region
has become wrapped up in the oil
industry and how the oil industry has
become a big sponsor of local cultural
festivals and museums and in part this
is sort of an effort to blunt critiques
and respond to people's critiques of
their new wealth and and and things like
this but it's it's it's very deeply
implicated in very local cultural
understandings there's a lot of research
about you know Russian nationalism being
based on oil wealth and at the very high
sort of federal statewide countrywide
Russian things but what I was finding
was that most people's entry levels to
identity were not national they were in
large part very local connected to the
region or the district or very very
particular cultural traditions so that
was an interesting and somewhat
surprising finding
so what about some of your other
findings sure well going back to you
know one of the original premises of the
book I said was to was to put Russia in
comparison with other places right yes
so tell us so so here's one so here's
just one example of a few that I deal
with the post-soviet oil industry in the
Perim region in the 1990s was built
largely on barter non-monetized exchange
and there's nothing in the West and in
many of the Western or post-colonial oil
producing countries it's all about oil
money I mean there's no commodity that
is more closely associated with money we
see it at every gas station the price in
money of oil Russia in the 1990s there's
because of state crises and economic
catastrophe basically people are trading
oil without money and many other things
without money so this this new oil elite
in this new industry and the place of
oil in that regional state apparatus was
very much built without money and and
that even though money is now quite a
hugely important thing in the 2000s that
history is still important for the
structure of things and peoples
instincts and expectations so are they
still bartering today as well as some
what I mean not not nearly to the extent
of the 1990s but somewhat I mean if you
look at many of the international deals
that Russia does in oil and gas
particularly with former Soviet
countries from you know mulled over
through Ukraine into Central Asia many
of these are in fact barter or part
barter deals and to get back to the
global scene if you look harder and
people haven't because they expect oil
and money to be so close to there's
actually a lot of global oil trade that
is barter and I think that changes the
way we should look at the oil industry
on a global scale and it's a kind of
thing we see particularly while if we
look at 1990s Russia which was such a
clear example of this but then once you
start looking you find you know China in
Africa these days many of these do these
deals for oil and Africa made by Chinese
companies are barter based you give us
the oil we build the dam there's not a
monetary transaction and so thinking
through those kinds of things enables us
to see from the perspective of Russia
something new about
the whole picture so in the area that
you look at it in Russia tell me about
the population no would it be mostly
middle class upper middle class I mean
or is there more of a hierarchy low
middle you know right absolutely an
excellent question one of the clear
things that the oil industry has been
involved in changing it is so the perm
region is about 2 million people about a
million in the main city of Parham the
rest spread out through the region in
what used to be Soviet agricultural
towns and a lot of heavy industry
defense industry things like this in
Soviet period the coming of the oil
industry in the post-soviet period has
dramatically increased inequality as a
lot of wealth has been concentrated in
those districts that are associated with
the oil industry and the people who work
for the oil companies so you find
enormous levels of inequality that you
certainly didn't have in the Soviet
period in this in this region that are
that are really traceable to the coming
of a particularly kind of capitalist oil
industry so there's inequality in the
area you study absolutely ok so some
people just missed the boat in terms of
getting involved with you know oil
companies or well that's a part of it um
you know part of it is just fortuitous
if there's oil under you or not um you
know this is an old American story as
well right where's the oil and who gets
it and so that's some of it's just sort
of accident of geography some of it is
the fact that the oil industry is
particular in that it's a fairly low
labor industry it's it needs you need a
lot of money and a lot of high
technology to extract oil but once
you've dug the well you only need a few
people there they bring to you so so the
population involved in the oil industry
is very small I see it's not like a mine
where you'd have like whole segments of
population involved in interesting I
didn't realize that so then are the oil
companies then you had mentioned that
them sponsoring a lot of different kinds
of events are they putting money back
into the culture in terms of education
that kind of thing yes they certainly
are and and so and in all of these
domains health care
education culture whether it's enough or
whether it's public relations campaign
or whether it's really only papering
over inequality and ecological damage is
one of the items of debate in the Perim
region as elsewhere in the oil-producing
world in the u.s. upstate New York or
Nigeria or or elsewhere but certainly
that's there and one of the
particularity with the way this has
happened in the post-soviet period is
that that practice of corporate
sponsorship grew up right alongside the
re-emergence of the state and they're
very closely tied together this is the
part of the argument of the book is that
the oil company in the healthcare
industry is very closely allied with the
state government in the healthcare
industry same for culture same for
education so these things are very
closely entwined not just that the level
of say the federal budget in Moscow but
at the level of practice in particular
regions and cities where the oil
industry operates do you foresee any
change in the future it's very hard to
predict and I have spent much of the
semester embarrassing myself in front of
my students with predictions about
Ukraine and Crimea in which I'm
constantly proven wrong on a daily basis
so I think I will abstain from the
prediction industry for for now okay and
then you know in terms of what do you
conclude in the book ultimately well I
think one of the main conclusions of the
book I mean there's all these little
conclusions about how it's working and
what the comparisons are but one of the
main conclusions and one of the main
takeaway points is that we really
haven't understood Russia as an
oil-producing country as well as we
should have
we need to understand not just things
about the federal budget or tax policy
or what the size of the oil company's
reserves is but really how oil and
culture and society have become twined
together in contemporary Russia and I
think a better understanding of that is
fairly crucial for for our
understandings of Russia in the
post-soviet period very good thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work well thank you
it's been a pleasure to talk
you for more information about professor
Rogers and his research please visit our
website at yale.edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale